good morning John it is one of the days
for you it's Friday for me
could be any could be any of the major
ones
any of the major seven of the days so
there's this young guy I started
following on Tick Tock after I got
cancer because he was talking about his
cancer story and he's still posting
videos uh but he also died
so that and the videos aren't like I'm
dead and they're just like his normal
content there is like funny videos so I
don't know whether he scheduled him
knowing he was going to be dead or not
knowing that but either way it makes you
think so I knew that there was going to
be a bunch of side effects to cancer and
chemotherapy but I did not realize that
there would be a bunch of like side
effects to stopping chemotherapy and
cancer I don't know if that's the right
way to say it one of the side effects of
not having cancer anymore that I is a
kind of a bonus I'm a universal donor O
Negative so like I always feel guilty
whenever I'm not donating but I don't
have to have that one anymore because
they will no longer let me donate my
blood so
Freedom I'm free of that one people told
me that this would happen when you lose
your hair because of chemo and then it
grows back you basically like re-roll
your whole head like it's your dungeon
and dragon's character you're rolling
for Charisma and for for strength and
stuff that happens for like all the hair
now you don't get to choose what you
roll but you do re-roll so if you had
curly hair you might have straight hair
if you had a straight hair curly hair if
you were bald you might get hair again
if you had hair you might be bald but
will lose their gray hair they'll gain
gray hair they will become Ginger like
this is not like lining up with how I
understand these things are supposed to
work and I haven't found any research
talking about how it works because it
doesn't seem like it matters that much I
mean compared to with all the rest of
what you go through it is fairly trivial
so having re-rolled my head I now appear
to have less head hair
I'm more bald I think I'm going to be
more bald than I was oh it might be
important for me to say here that I have
traditionally been the kind of guy who
could like get on a first name basis
with like all of his facial hairs I've
been mostly okay with this I've
attempted to do the goatee thing two
times out comes not fantastic but now I
might kind of be able to grow a beard
now I'm talking a big game here and I
don't know what's going to happen but
you might be looking at me and you're
thinking oh my God that doesn't look
like Hank Green that looks like a nerdy
Jason's teeth them you weren't thinking
that no one was thinking that I find
myself uh staring at beards like I was
at a housewarming party and I got like
really quite close to a friend of mine
who's more like a former colleague than
a friend and I was like oh I'm just
looking at how your beard hair grows in
because I don't know how that works like
do you have longer or more or darker or
thicker hair than me like What's it
gonna be like if all of this hair grows
in am I shaving correctly I'm not really
I think I went too high I'm over here
like a 43 year old man asking like teen
boy questions like is it normal for it
to be itchy I've never personally been
super worried about my facial hair
situation but this does make me
concerned because I know that there are
a lot of guys who work really hard to
try and get facial hair and I'm worried
that if they find out chemo can do that
they will find a way to start getting
keema and I just don't want to see chemo
beard trending on Tick Tock I think that
we all kind of get to keep posting after
we're gone not like on Tick Tock
necessarily but in a way right you know
all the words I'm saying right now are
words that some person that we've
forgotten came up with like culture and
thus I
and made up of millions of tiny little
influences from people that I don't know
about and can never know about we'll
never know about like me making words
and having thoughts is kind of them all
still posting what a thing to get to be
a part of another weird side effect of
getting done with chemotherapy is ocular
migraines which have not been fun uh
where I or I see like a little light
show before I start getting nauseous and
my head starts to throb but they don't
last very long for me so that's
something I guess to be grateful for and
of course the last of the most
interesting side effects are all
psychological we've got uh you know
health anxiety and I thought I thought I
honestly did that my work anxiety would
help distract me from my health anxiety
but it turns out at least so far that's
not how it's worked like I get work
anxiety and the feeling of the anxiety
triggers my health anxiety why does it
work that way y'all and also I didn't
think that this would happen to me but I
have a little tinge of the Survivor
guilt I feel like I don't have any like
space to talk about cancer because it
didn't hurt me enough and I know that
that's irrational but so are a lot of my
thoughts these days and we're just
working through them and then of course
there's like the most me specific side
effect which is that like despite
feeling you know tremendously necessary
for the last many years I was able to
just stop and go do what I needed to do
and that comes down to a lot of help
from a lot of people it comes down of
course to you John but also of course
there's lots of stuff that you didn't
know
and there are many people who are able
to sort of make it work and keep
everything not just like uh working but
moving forward and that felt really good
taking a step back from me slowing down
a little bit you know I think it would
have happened eventually but I did get
my hand forced a little bit and so we
did it and it turned out it was entirely
doable so despite the fact that I felt
like I was needed for everything I
wasn't and that's great news and also a
lesson to learn I mean it's not
surprising that I would be fascinated by
the idea of videos still coming out
after you're gone like what is it trying
to do what's it trying to say is it
trying to say like even though I know
I'm not going to be here
I still care what people are gonna think
about me after I'm gone or is it saying
this isn't about me I want to make
people laugh whether I'm here to see it
or not I want people to leave comments
whether I'm there to respond to them or
not maybe it's a way of saying like the
things that we make aren't really about
us and and it's interesting to ask like
what would you make if you knew people
would watch it
but you wouldn't be there to see how
they felt about it that's very different
from how I imagine creation oh and
having thought through what this video
is going to look like just for clarity
I'm not dead I didn't like make a bunch
of videos edit them and then die and
then schedule them like it seems like
especially because in the beginning I
didn't know what day it was that maybe
that's what I was implying no I'm a lie
I just legitimately didn't know what day
it was John I'll see you on Tuesday